[Music]
hey everybody i hope you are having a
really lovely pride month
and uh mine has been pretty nice i had a
had a really nice father's day as well
and i also got to watch with my kid
pixar's latest because
disney actually released it as part of
standard disney plus instead of making a
premium
access so luca i did a review of it over
in the break room of geeks and
i was pretty positive on it i'm not in
love with it i don't think it's amazing
but it's a nice
laid-back very positive feeling story
i had not really looked into anything
anyone was saying about it before
watching it or filming my review
so some stuff that went on in the
comments section of that
video caused me to do something that i
really shouldn't i i really shouldn't do
this
but i went out to see what the discourse
was saying about the film and apparently
there is a whole conversation going on
right now
about whether or not luca is
queerbaiting
this one caught me off guard a little
bit although
there are some reasons why maybe i would
have seen it coming under other
circumstances and i'll kind of get into
that
this is going to be a little bit of a
broader talk about
queerbaiting the way most people use the
term using luca as a
framework for that now i have done a
video on queerbaiting before
but i was talking in that video about a
very specific form
of queerbaiting what i was talking about
was
instances when creators studios
directors writers whoever
claim that there are characters or
relationships that
are in some form of queer some form of
lgbtqia plus representation
but it's absolutely not evidence in the
text the quintessential example of this
is jk rowling and her assertion that
dumbledore is gay something that
is not in evidence in the books or any
of the films that have been released
as yet so that that was the very
specific kind of
queerbaiting that i was railing against
there the queerbaiting that this is
being accused of is
a bit different than that because the
makers
very specifically said a couple months
before this came out that this
is not a love story for any characters
it's not even a matter of oh no the
characters are straight they didn't
actually say that they just said
the movie's not a love story so
this is not a case of the people behind
the scenes
claiming representation and then not
delivering on it
this is an instance of what is kind of a
bit more the classic accusation of
queerbaiting where people
look at a piece of media and say you
teased something that you then didn't
deliver on
now there's a reason that when i did my
video years ago
on queerbaiting why i picked that
specific kind because it was something
concrete a big part of queerbaiting and
why it can become
very much a heated argument very quickly
is it is largely interpretable
for me there's no interpretation to be
had when a creator says there's
representation and then i see the thing
and it's just not there unless you
squint and we're told in advance
and then maybe it's kind of there a
little there's no
defense of that but the thing is in
the kind of queerbaiting that luke is
being accused of
it's really down to personal
interpretation
and unless uh the we get a lot and a ton
of really frank discussions with the
people behind the scenes we're never
going to know about intentionality
and for me at least that's the heart of
true
queerbaiting is knowing what
you're doing because look can we be
honest for a minute
it is very possible for someone
who is straight cisgender to
write something into a story that works
as an allegory or stand-in for queer
representation and not
realize that they did that the x-men are
an excellent example
these are characters who their mutant
powers manifest
around puberty about the same age a lot
of folks
start to figure out their sexuality or
their gender identities
and it's something that is looked down
upon they are ostracized for it but it's
also something they can't help
it works amazingly well as a queer
allegory but it was not designed to be
another really good example lord of the
rings
however much you love it j.r.r tolkien
did not
intend to write a same-sex romantic
entanglement between sam and frodo
now the movie did lean into that
bro a little bit but the original books
no he didn't
intend that to be there but it still can
be read that way things like that
i do not consider to be on the table for
queerbaiting
because they didn't mean to
and i think there's a very key
difference between
allegory and applicability
because to look at luca for a minute and
i will avoid spoilers
as much as i possibly can on this right
now i'm just going to talk pre
uh general premise in lucca
you have these undersea people that
the surface considered to be sea
monsters
luca is one of these when he comes above
ground
he looks human when he's dry so he
passes
he meets another one like him who
wants to be more involved in the surface
world
they are feared by the people on the
surface they are called
monsters it is believed that they are
dangerous
they bond very closely with each other
and they do
eventually find other people that they
would like to be more open with who they
are about but
they just fundamentally believe it isn't
safe this absolutely works
and is applicable as a queer story and
of course
the two main characters alberto and luca
these two boys have a wonderful
relationship and a wonderful bond and i
even said in my original review that you
can
read it that way but it's also
applicable to a ton of other things
you could apply that same kind of
mentality to
my gosh almost anything you could apply
it to certain kinds of
disability be on the autism spectrum
just being a certain kind of race and
possibly being
say for instance a white passing black
person
there are plenty of other things that
it's applicable to and that's not to say
it definitively is any of these things
or that it's definitively anything
because again that's the thing allegory
is on purpose
the line of which the wardrobe and the
entire narnia series is an
allegory for christianity it's
deliberate
that was what was supposed to be there
was the direct intention of csus when he
wrote it
applicability it can be intended but
it can also be much further reaching
than the creators ever intended
so i personally right now don't see
evidence in regards to luca that there
was
an intention to have it be more
applicable
to queer identities than to anything
else
now i do want to say one thing or rather
circle back into something i said
earlier i did say that
you know the circumstances under which i
watch it and under other ones i might
think something else and here's what i
mean by that
before watching this i did not look into
anything going on about it any other
conversations about it or anything like
that now the reason i bring that up
is because depending on the four
knowledge i come into a film
i am gonna think of it differently so
like an example of that
with the solo movie solo a star wars
story we were told
in interviews that lindo calrissian
was pansexual and
i went into the movie looking for
evidence of that
not expecting to find it and not really
finding it
either any more than vague vague hints
that
really don't float or hold water i'm
mixing metaphors
whatever it doesn't do it it just
doesn't but
i knew going in that they'd said it was
there so i was looking for it
now if i hadn't read those things before
i would have gone into it and just
watched the movie and just probably
enjoyed it at least a little bit more
than i did
and that was sort of the way i came into
luca i didn't have any foreign knowledge
or any expectation
because apparently there's been a fair
amount of internet buzz about the
possibility that this
could be a young gay pairing these two
young these two boys
you know starting to learn and i don't
mean gay parent like oh they're going to
get on like you know
like a young crush the way lots of
heteronormative relationships are shown
in all kinds of kids media so
i talked about this just last week so
anyways
i wasn't aware of any of that
conversation and when your head's
already in that space you're gonna come
into the film
looking for how things fit into that
conversation you've already been having
now does that mean that you
automatically see things that
aren't there no but you are going to be
more sensitive to whatever is there and
possibly read more into it than was
intended but again that's not to say
that it isn't there
so like some of the things people have
brought up that i've seen
a lot of people talk about in terms of
the overall structure and the italian
setting
as a connection to call me by your name
which at this point is one of the more
prominent recent
films to feature a gay male pairing i
haven't actually seen call me by your
name i'm not sure if i ever will now
because i didn't get around to it before
uh army hammer was better known as
doing stuff army hammer seems to have
been about but anyways i don't know if
i'll ever get around to that so i can't
confirm solidly how much it does or
doesn't sort of
uh graft onto the template of call me by
your name
what i can tell you though is that there
are a number of references and
influences that this thing wears very
much on its
sleeve and that doesn't appear to be one
of them there's a poster in the
background for the italian film lestrada
and the whole vibe has
kind of a uh more laid back that is very
much in keeping with
a lot of films from that part of the
world and honestly i'm ashamed that i
missed this one
the name of the town is porto rosso
which
really i i cannot believe this was not
intentional given how much we know the
people at pixar love miyazaki
one of miyazaki's films was porco rosso
and that was also set in italy which
actually might account
for these slightly miyazaki-esque vibes
i was getting off the thing
so again my point is is that i'm not
going to say there's no evidence
to queerbaiting people also cited being
released in the month of june
which feels like a stretch like look
june's pride month
that's well known at this point disney
definitely knows it they sell enough
pride merchandise during the month
but like are we just gonna say you can't
release any movie that isn't gay
during june like it it's a summer month
it's one of the busy months for
movies so i don't know like i
i get i do understand i do get why this
confluence of things and then just
general frustration with disney
and mainstream representation in general
particularly in kids media and honestly
particularly
with masculine relationships something
that i've noted i don't know if i have
enough to say about it to get a video
out of it yet but something i have
noticed is that
in media aimed at kids you get a lot
of lesbian pairings you don't get a lot
of gay male pairings
like as much as i love things like
shiran the princesses of power or the
owl house or how many good things that i
have heard
about steven universe or adventure time
like
it's all two girls and like that's great
that's wonderful but i have started to
notice a
disinclination in this media to depict
two boys so if you're
hoping to find that kind of
representation specifically yeah i
absolutely get the frustration
i i absolutely sincerely do
but again i'm not really feeling like i
see it here
if i'm being completely honest i'm kind
of of the opinion that queerbaiting in a
film is kind of
really difficult to prove and often just
not of something worth kind of delving
into it almost
i'm not going to say impossible but
really unlikely here's why queerbaiting
in a
film a standalone film is actually kind
of rare
it's much more prevalent in television
anything
ongoing because that is a case where
the creators become aware of the
audience aware of the audience's
expectations
aware of what the audience hopes to see
and can start
deliberately toying and messing with
them and
baiting them most of the more egregious
examples where i think there is
actually tangible evidence that the
creators knew fully well what they were
doing
and did it anyway and it just comes off
as kind of mean
are things like bbc sherlock
supernatural
even the the film series that i can
think of that people have accused of
queerbaiting are things that have been
around for a long time
long enough for their fans to have built
expectations things like
star wars or the mcu even if you're
gonna make those arguments
i still feel like queerbaiting is
something that happens to something that
goes on for a long time
happening in a one-off film it's
pretty uncommon and
my own personal experience viewing the
film i came away thinking
i was so happy at how wholesome the
relationship between these two boys was
and i should clarify when i say
wholesome i don't mean not sexual i mean
wholesome as in
not toxic because so often
depictions of relationships between
young boys
even platonic ones contain a lot of
toxic elements there's so often this
competitiveness this one upsmanship
this desire to be better or this
sort of sense of jealousy or whatever
and none of that's here
it's just a wonderful bonding
relationship
between these two and i was just happy
to see that because
i feel like i don't see that very much
i feel like i don't see this kind of
close-knit
wholesome and stable relationship
between two male characters who aren't
like siblings who aren't brothers or
something
it's really rare and i was just happy to
see that
now i can again concede that
if i had been hoping for and waiting for
seeing two male characters in a disney
movie be confirmed as a couple
then yeah i probably would have thought
it's just nice to see that
too i personally didn't really see it
in lucca but again i wasn't tapped into
the conversations that were going on
ahead of time
and while i've seen some you know cases
made
it comes back to a large part of the
reason why i generally don't talk about
queer baiting
in the broadest sense because
it kind of depends on interpreting the
intention of the creators
and that's much easier to do in
something like a show
or something that is long running
because you can look at patterns
patterns will absolutely reveal more
about intentionality
one-off films
oftentimes it can really involve a heck
of a lot more armchair psychology and
trying to
just parse the thought process of
creators and
companies then i'm frankly comfortable
doing when it comes to creative works
like this
were those kinds of things in their
heads they say they weren't
could they be lying yeah but then we're
getting into the kind of conspiratorial
narrative that
i'm just not comfortable doing i will
say this
if we ever find out a later date from
someone behind the scenes of
luca at pixar that they very much wanted
to make this a queer story but were shut
down
by people higher up either within pixar
or disney if that ever comes out oh yeah
i'm gonna
talk about that like you wouldn't
believe
but without that i'm not
seeing this as at least not the
strongest
incidence of queerbaiting i'm not going
to say definitively that it's not
because i don't want to invalidate
people's feelings and like i said
i'm not quite as dialed into all this as
i know some people
are so i'm not trying to shut anybody
down if they did come away from this
film feeling like they were baited
but i i do feel comfortable saying it's
not the strongest case
for this kind of thing and that's where
i land
on all of this what do you think about
it have you seen luca
did you get these vibes from it were you
pleasantly surprised to get these vibes
were you frustrated by these vibes
whatever your thoughts are what do you
think about queerbaiting in general
what are your most egregious examples
whatever your thoughts are politely
leave them down in the comments and
let's talk about it
usual stuff like share subscribe i have
a patreon that is how i pay my bills
keeps this whole operation up and
running but you don't have to do that
there are rewards for every tier but
there's also youtube memberships but
even if you don't want to do that
the other stuff i mentioned helps me out
as well
but you don't have to do any of it
because what i really want you to
remember is that you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
hope you have a good rest of pride
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you um
[Music]